I just have to start shooting this video
or else I'm just going to talk myself
out of this oh it's one of those days
weeks months years we are 2 weeks into
the new year it's good good it's good
hello welcome I hope I'm in focus should
I get new equipment that usually solves
all your problems right what kind of
cameras is everyone using these days is
this oh that's direct okay great we're
doing great it's 11:25 I'm going to make
healthy pad tie at 11:25 in the morning
nothing can stop me other than all the
things that have already tried to stop
me I've gone to the store twice to get
ingredients that I've forgotten I should
say I've gone to the stores I went to
one store this morning to get some
things and then I came back and I
realized I needed other things so I went
to a different store because somehow I
felt shame going back into the same
store thriving we're making choices and
at the top of the Year we're trying to
make a choice towards Health not sure
exactly why but Health has become a
priority but I also do not want to deny
my raccoon roots that just wants
objectively not healthy food all of the
time so I thought I would bridge the gap
and try to make healthier versions of
not as healthy food and yes do I realize
I'm spending a lot of time and a lot of
money probably making a very mediocre
pad tie for myself Yes again these are
the grace hell big choices that make up
the grace hell big person and the grace
hell big experience is the experience
easy and calm all the time no but it's
quite an experience let's experiment
with some healthier cooking this year
Lord knows we have quite a library of
some unhealthy cooking in the archives
if you'd like to visit those I don't
know what's back there at this point I
found a recipe online that had really
good reviews it is from the cleaneating
couple.com I'm sure they're lovely but
that just off the name does not sound
like a couple you want to invite to a
party maybe this year though who am I to
judge my hair is in quite and in between
stage it's thin these days so my head
gets cold so you see we are sporting the
beanie almost all the time we have
become quite where Waldo in our
aesthetic appearance we're just in that
weird lemon old
space we haven't even started doing this
let's start cooking the clean eting
couple.com I'll link the recipe down
below if you're interested these are
most of the ingredients these are the
amount of ingredients I've decided I'm
okay with having to to start this recipe
we're making chicken pad tie so we have
chicken the tendies we're going to cut
chicken into 1 in squares and sauté in a
pan with olive oil for 12 to 15 minutes
until completely browned and cooked
apologies to vegetarians out there tofu
seems like an alternative I'm doing
chicken I need protein this needs
some protein this year knife hello
sitting over there I should have a
separate cutting board for the chicken
yes we'll just put it right on top of
this one let's cut it into little pieces
so this is about the time of year where
we all realize our resolutions
are should I even talk while I'm doing
this haphazardly cutting this chicken
trying not to cut our own fingers
because they look very much like this
raw chicken I don't really see much of a
difference chicken's cut I'm going to
turn this camera on over here so you can
watch the chicken cook you Heathen I got
to chop some vegetables I need half a
cup of a chopped onion and a tablespoon
of garlic and one cup I need a bell pepp
we're starting to get a bit scattered
we're going to put our chicken in that
pan cook it Meanwhile we're going to cut
up half a cup of onion a tablespoon of
garlic and a cup of bell pepper go te I
need a new
knife thly threatening and friendly oh
god I've realized that I'm not the most
fun person to watch chop things I think
I make people
nervous wow chopped onions did I wash
the bell pepper I didn't I think I did
before I don't know you trust me it's
I'm not making this it's not going in
your mouth I'll wash it I'll wash it I
feel your guilt excellent knife skills
I'm just going to cut up one little
garlic clove to put more oil in here
chaotic the cooking is never soothing
gives me somewhere to put all the
nervous energy always smart to put it
into knives later today I'm getting a CT
mapping scan of my body it's going to
determine my radiation treatment am I
nervous no I just got to take my top off
and lift my arms up in a room with some
medical professionals I already bought
the carrots shredded so that Parts done
oo la la bring a pot of water to a boil
and cook the rice noodles according to
the directions on the package they asked
for you to use brown rice noodles I
think that's what these are pad tie rice
noodles Brown boil in water for up to 5
minutes I'm bringing a pot of water to a
boil so I can cook the noodles in it
just keeping you a breast of the
situation that's how I should have told
my friends and family that I had breast
cancer I'd like to keep you a breast of
a serious situation it's of the cancer
variety the chicken has been cooked
leave oil in the pan okay now we're
going to add our peppers carrots garlic
and onion sauté for 10 minutes after 10
minutes you can stir in bean sprouts I
didn't buy bean sprouts why because they
taste like wet packing material you know
it I know it we all know it someone had
to say it also my grocery store didn't
have them that I could see in the 5
minutes I gave myself to get in and out
of that grocery store let's cook our
vegetables in this pan with this oil and
this chicken residue M who doesn't love
a good veggie coated in chicken residue
oo I'm under socialized let's put all
this in there right all at once all at
once here we go very confident oh no the
onions went everywhere garlic and we put
some carrots in 10 minutes how are you
good are you good oh I need to whisk
together the sauce ingredients I have
yet to do that look clear glass bowls
like professional cooking chefs so that
you can see what I'm doing because it
always looks good a tablespoon of peanut
butter oh do they make peanut butter
scented candles no they simply should
not I get so high and eat the out of
that there's nothing like a value sized
jar of peanut butter to make my maternal
instincts kick in I just want to cradle
you and spoon feed you into my mouth
okay that's about a tablespoon and it's
not poison tablespoons of honey I'm
going to eyeball
this this is personification of I felt
that 2 tbsps of lime juice maybe I
should have measured 1 and 1/2 tbsp of
rice wine vinegar I am going to measure
this 1 and 1/2 tablespoon right yes
wow oh that like gets up in the butthole
of your spine nasal senses 2 tspoons of
fish sauce why won't you let me in you
smelly smelly thing verbatim how Elliot
CED me this is unreason ow bending back
my nails this is unreasonable she is a
calming presence in the kitchen says the
New York Times this is fragrant wow wow
wow fish sauce you're a white a present
a four cup of low sodium soy sauce or
coconut aminos bam okay now we mix this
together is this how it's supposed to
look look this looks wild my water is
boiling and I need to focus on the
noodles now so we will just set that
aside but we'll think about it
constantly and how we might have done
this wrong no it's it's coming together
we're going to cook our noodles for 5
minutes right that's what it says I do
the whole pack 5 oz this is 8.8 oz so I
use a little over
half bam oh push vegetables to one side
of the pan and crack eggs into the pan
scramble eggs until cooked approximately
2 minutes this is going to get
interesting our p fan of vegetables is
very burnt looking and looks like it's
been through some but we're going
to move the veggies to the side and
crack two eggs in the pan that's easy
choreography for this very good Chef
we're going to crack two eggs oh God
trying to cook healthy is so stressful
there's one egg one egg's in I know I
know all this work and effort for what
will be a very mediocre pad tie probably
I know but we'll see maybe it'll
surprise and Delight me we can't keep
writing everything off so cynically and
negatively what if we give things a
chance hope it's a lost art the are
these eggs doing we have to scramble
them stir it all together and removed
from the pan and set aside with the
chicken I mean that looks good that
looks like a thing that looks like
something how is this sauce doing you
look
so okay you look okay hope is what we're
holding on to hope is the gas on the
fire of
accomplishment I know I unsubscribed
just then too add sauce to the mixture
add the wait what are
the what are the noodles doing rinse
noodles under cold water to cool we're
going to we're going to rinse our
noodles off always handle the nudes
first you know that I know that oh God
why did I start pouring it before I got
to the sink what is wrong with
me it's okay we were just excited rinse
the noodles now this says if you're
still with me I hope we're going to add
the sauce mixture to this pan that has
seen better days let it bubble and slice
thicken and then we're going to add the
okay let's just one at a time that's
going to boil for about a minute then
we're going to add the veggies the
chicken and the noodles into the pan
with the sauce and toss to combine and
then I'm going to Plate it up for us oh
this is worth it this is worth it this
is what health looks
like let's try the fruit fruits of our
labor M we put a lot of lime juice in
there oh wow I think that's pretty good
I also think that my taste buds have
started to come back which was another
Catalyst for me to want to start cooking
again I think that's really good I think
that's really good the textures are
there the slop level that pad thai has
that
like that's there m okay that's really
good it does taste lighter than a pad
tie it's really good for what it is a
healthier version of pad tie yeah okay
and there's a ton of it over there so
this I think was good this was good this
was good it's good to see you how do you
feel I feel good this is delicious I
really enjoy this wow how fun thank you
for joining me on another cooking
Adventure I'd like to explore more
healthy versions of potentially
unhealthy Foods so maybe we'll do more
of that in the future let me know other
things that you think I should cook or
find healthier versions of attempt
healthier versions of and we'll see you
next time other than that I don't know I
don't don't know